THAT THE HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN MCCARTHY WAS BRIEFED ON
A MEMO ABOUT TERRORISTS SUSPECTS
CAUGHT AT THE U.S.-MEXICO
BORDER.
HE IS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
AMERICA'S SECURITY THAN EVER
PERFECT.
WHAT IT WILL TAKE FOR DEMOCRATS
TO BE HONEST WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE INSTEAD OF SUBSTITUTING
POLITICAL THEATRE FOR REAL
SOLUTIONS ON EVERY ISSUE?
IMMIGRATION AND RECKLESS
SPENDING AND PLAYING THE RACE
CARD WITH THE APPROVAL OF WOKE
CORPORATE AMERICA.
REPUBLICANS ARE FIGHTING BACK
WITH ADS LIKE THIS.
>> AMERICAN AIRLINES RATED THE
WORST.
THEY REQUIRE AMERICANS TO SHOW
I.D. TO FLY BUT ATTACKED TEXAS'S
VOTER I.D. LAW.
>> Sean: JOE'S STATE OF DELAWARE
THEY HAVE VOTER I.D.
DON'T EXPECT ANY CRITICAL
COVERAGE FROM THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA ON ANY OF THIS.
WE ARE LEARNING TONIGHT THEY
MIGHT BE SCARED OF ENDING UP ON
KAMALA HARRIS'S BAD LIST.
A NEW REPORT UNCOVERED THAT
HARRIS KEEPS TABS ON JOURNALISTS
WHO DON'T APPRECIATE HER LIFE
EXPERIENCE.
HERE WITH REACTION SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF THAT?
>> WELL, THAT'S A LOT OF TO
UNPACK.
LET'S START WITH THE BORDER.
WE ARE INVITING A TERRORIST
ATTACK ON OUR COUNTRY ON THE
20th ANNIVERSARY OF 9-11 LOSING
CONTROL OF THE BOARD.
HOW HARD TO PUT TERRORISTS IN
THE FLOW OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
CROSSING OUR BORDER.
STANDING WITH ISRAEL.
I WILL BE IN CHARLESTON, SOUTH
CAROLINA TOMORROW NIGHT RALLYING
CHRISTIANS AND THE ISRAELI
COMMUNITY TO STAND WITH ISRAEL.
TWO THINGS I AM CERTAIN OF.
HAMAS WOULD KILL EVERY ISRAELI
IF THEY COULD.
THE ONLY REASON THEY ARE NOT IS
BECAUSE ISRAEL CAN DEFEND
ITSELF.
ISRAEL COULD KILL TENS OF
PALESTINIANS IF THEY WANTED DO.
THEY DON'T.
THEY WANT TO LIVE IN PEACE.
TO DEMOCRATS COLLEAGUES PUSHING
ISRAEL TO STOP KILLING HAMAS,
YOU ARE WRONG.
ISRAEL YOU DO WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO TO PROTECT YOURSELF.
WE HAVE YOUR BACK.
>> Sean: DON'T STOP UNTIL YOU
GET EVERY HAMAS TERRORIST YOU
KAY.
THEY TAKE GREAT CONCERN IN
PROTECTING INNOCENT LIFE, BUT
HAMAS THEY FIRED THE MISSILES
FROM AND HOSPITALS.
IF INNOCENT PEOPLE DIE, THAT'S
ON THEM.
THEY ARE FIRING THOUSANDS OF
ROCKETS INTO ISRAEL.
GOING BACK TO THE BORDER.
90% OF HEROIN AND 90% OF
FENTANYL KILLING AMERICANS EVERY
WEEK CROSSES THAT BORDER.
NOW PEOPLE ON THE LEFT ARE
DEFENDING GANG MEMBERS FROM
DEPORTATION AND CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK GIVING CHECKS TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
I THINK I HAVE HEARD IT ALL.
>> WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING BUT
TAKE AN AD OUT IN THE PAPER,
COME TO AMERICA.
JOE BIDEN IS OVERWHELMED BY THE
JOB OF BEING PRESIDENT.
THE LEFT LOST ITS MIND.
THERE IS MORE FENTANYL ACROSS
THE BORDER AT THIS TIME IN 2021
THAN IN ALL OF 2020.
TO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION YOU
WOULD BE INSANE TO NEGOTIATE
WITH IRAN AS LONG AS THEY ARE
STILL THE STATE SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM.
I AM WORRIED ABOUT OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AND OUR BORDER HERE AT
HOME.
2022 WILL BE A HELL OF AN
ELECTION.
IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE PERSON
AND YOU DON'T VOTE IN 2022 YOU
HAVE NOBODY TO BLAME BUT
YOURSELF.
I MISS DONALD TRUMP.
NONE OF THIS WOULD HAPPEN IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT
TODAY.
I HOPE HE CONSIDERS RUNNING.
HE CAN GO TO THE AMERICA PEOPLE
AND SAY LET ME FINISH WHAT I
STARTED.
WHAT I DID WORK.
>> Sean: I LIKE FOCUS ON HIS
AGENDA.
IT WORKED.
ANY TIME THOSE POLICIES ARE
IMPLEMENTED IT WORKS.
PUTIN AND KIM JONG-UN AND XI IF
CHINA THEY FEARED TRUMP.
THEY DON'T FEAR THIS GUY.
>> YOU GOT IT.
THEY ARE CLEANING OUR CLOCK.
WHEN TRUMP WAS THE